prescription drug use is off the charts
bonkers right now 70% of Americans are
on prescription drugs let's look at some
numbers okay
70% of those that are on at least one so
many of them are on more than that and
you know you have to take your ambit a
fly to supplement your well abou trend
and blah blah blah that's a 50% increase
from 2007 to 2010 so it's probably
higher than that right now 50% of
Americans are on at least two
prescription drugs and 20% of Americans
are on five or more prescription drugs
20% are on five or more prescription
drugs I'm not going to ask either one of
you specifically how many prescription
drugs you are taking these numbers seem
horrific to me like this is maybe a
bigger problem that we have in America
than anything else at the moment and to
me it's so obvious where it's coming
from
it's the commercialization of it I mean
there really wasn't a way they finally
figured out how to put them on
television with the smiley faces and the
dogs jumping and the happiness and
people are like oh great the the
requests people are going into their
doctors saying hey I saw a commercial
for this I would like it please there
was a little cartoon chasing me so
that's and they I think it's so funny
that they don't air those commercials on
radio there's no drug commercials on
radio because they don't work because
there are no happy that's an interesting
point so if you're in your car yes
listening to it you're still seeing
trees or people so your brain but if you
see a depressing play oh what do you
think I think I think a lot has to do
with that I also think in the study it
says that a lot of them are
antidepressants and I think the economy
had a huge hand in that people lost
their homes people lost their jobs
people lost their lifestyle they lost
their nest egg their retirement so even
ordinary people that maybe would not
have been depressed or don't have
depression in their family or whatever
it is are now finding themselves down in
the dumps because of you know what has
happened
but isn't that just
of life what that ten years ago or 20
years ago certainly that was just part
of life and now because of the marketing
machine it's like oh I'm a little
depressed like I lost my job acceptable
now I think before being depressed was
like you know everyone was quiet and
didn't want to admit it and it was like
the stigma that was on and I think now
people are like hey I need help I need
some you know whatever or we're in the
Society of the Internet where we want
immediate gratification
we're like push button getting results
you know so I think instead of like you
said like just getting over it or maybe
doing some meditation or some therapy
people like give me a pill give me a
pill wait what's gonna fix it I don't
want to go you know people know how to
lose weight they know how to how to work
out they know what they should and
shouldn't be eating you don't need a
book to tell you that you know six
pieces of cake before you go to sleep
it's probably not a good idea all right
either way they want right you care you
hear first ah
either way they want a pill that's going
you a quick trim or whatever it is
that's gonna fix them right away so I
think it's the same thing and I think
you know with the internet they're going
on there and they're not only seen these
commercials but I mean I diagnose myself
all the time on WebMD and my gosh I
haven't sneaky you know right exactly
and you went for the word cancer to come
up here like I'm sweet it makes me think
of that episode of The Simpsons when
they when mr. burns goes to the clinic
and they tell him that he has absolutely
every disease known to man and but
they're in perfect balance so that he
can't get sick and that's what I feel
like when I'm on there I'm like I have
everything right hysterical pregnancy
everything do you guys do you guys think
that in these commercials because I do
think that's the root of this whole
thing that they should have to show you
the side effects not just list them
because literally about 40% of the
commercials just saying diarrhea nausea
possible suicide detriment but they
never show that instead it's a guy in a
field that he's running in someone
you're kids any gonna doing all this
amazing stuff but if they actually
showed you puking on the toilet and jump
and having us hanging yourself and maybe
jumping over do you think that that
might put your diet people you have that
idea absolutely because they're saying
may cause prostate cancer as the man is
smiling and lovingly and his spouse like
sexual dysfunction right you won't be
able to get these people they take
viagra to get a boner then they get
depressed now they can't get a boner
then
take Cialis because they need a longer
bond cream where if you accidentally
touch your wife and with the cream on
your hand she will grow a beard so call
your doctor right oh the one it'll put
hair on your head but if your wife
touches it it'll kill the unborn baby
this is why people are on five or more
for sure they take one and the side
effects of this one they need three
others and the side effects of those
they need you know and it's a
never-ending train you know there's a
sidebar to this so I was I don't really
like to fly and I went to a psychiatrist
to get xanax to fly and that was all I
wanted he told me that I have time shift
disorder what and that there was a new
pill that he wanted me to take and I
kept saying him I swear to god this is
true and I kept saying to him no no I
just want an X I just want to be able to
pass out on the plane that's it
he wouldn't he literally would not let
me leave without a prescription for it
so I took the prescription which I
proceeded to throw away but even his
tape dispenser on his desk was at head
Sally wasn't zoloft but it was something
I was thinking and the weed dealer has
never been like please you want me to
you got some crack to know what we do is
like yeah so it doesn't that show you
the the system is just the doctors
there's oh god I don't yeah back to the
future they would have mentioned it I'm
saying that was a real thing you could
get back to the nineteen no exactly I
think that has a lot to do with it I
mean look doctors are it's a business at
the end of the day yes they want to help
you yes you know hopefully they're there
for the right reasons other than you
know their Bentley but when it comes
down to it they are a freelance person
they work for themselves and these drug
companies are making a ton of money and
they are giving them incentives whether
it be perks gifts money checks kickbacks
whatever it is
so obviously that doctor was getting
something for you know for giving you
that and making making you go out and
get that medication I don't think he
genuinely thought he needed it because
you would have just said look
time-shifter that you made up
imaginary thing time shift disorder
alright well I hope that we've inspired
you a little bit and not depressed you
to have to go take the pills you're on
or go get a whole set of new ones
I want to thank Jackie Geary fake Jackie
Geary on the Twitter and Vanessa Gomez
that's Vanessa M Gomez on Twitter and
joy for it so get out there and have
some fun get away from your computer for
a little bit and see what happens okay